[Music]
vancouver i'll be at the house of comedy
september 15th through the 17th tickets
available ryanstickler.com
i got my passport and my night pass
ready
[Music]
edmonton september 29th through october
1st and chicago i will see you all
november 11th and 12th get tickets to
all shows on my website at
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pass
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media and as always thank you for
supporting the show the community is
continuing to grow and grow i love you
guys for it if you're watching on
youtube please hit that subscribe button
it helps it means nothing to you and
everything to us all right
also if you want more the patreon's out
there it's called the honeydew with
y'all i'm highlighting the lowlights
with you all and y'all got the craziest
[ __ ] stories i've ever heard in my
life all right it's five bucks a month
if you sign up for a year you get over a
month free you get the honeydew a day
early you get it ad free at no
additional cost all right if you or
somebody you know has a story it has to
be heard please submit the
honeydewpodcast gmail.com hopefully we
get to do an episode together all right
that's the biz there you guys know uh
the tour is still rolling on i can't
thank you enough for your support there
vancouver september 15th through the
17th edmonton september 29th through
october 1st chicago november 11th and
the 12th all right that's the business
you guys know we do over here we
highlight the low lights i say all the
time these are the stories behind the
storytellers i am very excited to have
this guest on
first time here on the do ladies and
gentlemen please welcome nick doom
welcome to the honeydew nicktoon thank
you thank you for being here nick yeah
that was a big intro i appreciate it
you're welcome i'm i i'm excited i like
what i do i love my guests i like what
their stories are
uh and you're no exception young man i
said to you when you walked up like dude
just [ __ ] hang this comedy [ __ ] up
model why don't why are you [ __ ]
around why i mean you said something to
me before that you saw me do something
quite miraculous i would say first of
all
let's give you props so
back in the day am i allowed to talk
about this nick you could tell me my cat
did a honda commercial okay okay yeah
and honda and he went back and forth on
negotiations and nick was like
and was like what about a new car and
they wanted him to take a honda fit and
he's like i'm i'll tell you six what
four four six four five sixteen in
canada five sixteen in canada and uh he
was like now i'm gonna need that honda
ridgeline and they gave him a honda
ridgeline and i'm a big fan of the honda
ridgeline i've driven one my cousin has
one and this [ __ ]
uh parallel parked beautifully like i've
had no idea anyone was watching it was
just honestly just for me i'm just out
there having a little smoke watching
them it was on santa monica boulevard it
wasn't like a simple
neighborhood street where i could just
take cars are coming
pressure and it was a one and done one
and done and then i look over and guess
who watched the whole thing happen
it was not only a one and done it was a
one and done to where i landed with both
tires on the curb and
properly cocked because you will get a
ticket out here for some [ __ ] that
don't yeah
yeah was already like that yeah left
like boom all you got to do is turn it
off put it in [ __ ] park you're good i
didn't even have to change the steering
to get out of that spot which i did get
out because you let me know that there
was a free spot yeah don't pay this city
70 dollars and i think not after you
park like that a lot of people deserve
your money no i think a lot of people
that have a bigger ego would say no that
parking job i can't move it but for me
it was like i'll throw that away okay if
you would have took it
it's gonna be an hour before you get out
uh all right before we begin uh please
plug promote everything
um
well i
i was trying to figure out my states but
all i got right now is october 8th
chicago at the den theater
which is going to be
just a brilliant show
i had a i've got like some european
stuff i think coming up that i haven't
nailed down yet but how's your european
audience
i mean london's really supportive yeah
um i would say london's very support i
don't know about how much any more
europe over there
australia is super supportive yeah not
europe but still yeah outside of the
united states about europe you know
because there's americans there that are
using like local like
dns codes on their like computers to get
to gain things and so
you're probably getting ping that
someone in arizona's watching it but
really it's
some hot chick in paris
oh oui
um all right you're here to actually
real quick just where can they get all
your dates whenever they're coming to
see you what's your website where my
website's been having troubles
[Music]
that's gonna be the theme of this
episode
my my self promotion is i mean i i post
everything on instagram so that's kind
of it i have like a daily relationship
with my instagram followers
um
and i'll let people know about dates on
there usually i put it all together in a
tour post the tour put like a little
flyer post or whatever
i put a lot of care into that stuff but
you think if i did that i would have my
website dialed in well you did something
that just
sparked my memory right now a while back
where um i thought was really
interesting didn't you uh promote on a
billboard did you buy a billboard and
promote that's what a lot of people
think yeah that's what they think what
was it what i hired a graphic designer
and this was i think
i think there was instagram but it
wasn't it was mostly twitter yeah it was
early
i got like i i made this whole story up
where i got you know comedy central gave
me a thousand dollars to promote my
special
and i decided to do it on or netflix
netflix gave me a thousand bucks and i
decided to do like the one billboard i
could afford which is on like a freeway
in central oregon somewhere yeah
and
just like posted it you know it's good
when like comedians are like man that's
cool it's like oh you couldn't tell that
that was obviously fake you know but
like that was awesome i created kind of
a whole story around it and then some
people were like i wish i would have
just kept thinking it was real because
it seems kind of like you're a liar now
and so i had to deal with that fallout
yeah with friends fall out
fall out
um all right
i know we're going to talk about rehab
today and i know you you
everyone sends their topics in before
you
you say rehab at 17. that's really early
to go to rehab so let's talk about what
leads us there you're originally from
seattle i know yeah um and what's your
upbringing like
very you know
i would say like the lowest of middle
class in a neighborhood where people are
more upper middle class you know but
they're i think it was also people that
weren't too flashy with their money you
know in this neighborhood
but like all my friends were walking
around in jordans and and stuff you know
even though their houses weren't like
insane but like back then that was a big
deal to have jordan so i know i never
had a pair no i wanted a pair so bad and
my mom showed up with a pair of the
shaquille o'neals that she got on sale
at like nordstrom or something i
remember those just like black i'm
ripping the
backboard down black and purple suede
i mean and i was the kid that like i
grew i became six four when i was like
15. damn did you really have the feet of
somebody that was six four when i was
like 11.
so you guys go into your feet yeah those
shaquille o'neal it's like a puppy you
know when you see a puppy with a big
feet you're like oh they're gonna turn
out all right
but uh
yeah so i had these like huge moon boots
on but i think that was also kind of the
what led me down this path was
everything i got wasn't as good as my
friends and everyone around was pretty
materialistic in the sense of a starter
jacket you know all the things that like
mattered at that age the dumbest [ __ ]
like you i'm you're speaking to me
because i never had a real pair of vans
they were always a knockoff checker pair
but they weren't vans we never had jams
they were a big pair of uh like shorts
board shirts yeah so my mom would sew
[ __ ] like make our own from joanne
fabrics like jesus christ they're
ripping and [ __ ] like come on man
everybody knows you think jam
everyone thinks these are jellies
[Laughter]
it was always
secondhand or a knockoff or you know
just and back then stores well [ __ ] it
was kmart and they had stuff called
mcgregor you know i mean now target's
got [ __ ] tony hawk and yeah people
quality [ __ ] that you're not gonna get
bullied for and get your ass kicked
because you don't have the cool stuff
anything i mean and you know one one
story that i always remember is my dad
took me out to get a baseball glove
and he took me it was called olympic
sports i don't even know still exist up
in the northwest but
and i came home it was probably a 40
baseball glove and it was the same one
my friends had
and i was so excited and i think i was
home for five minutes before my mom put
me in her car drove me back returned it
and then got the cheapest one they had
and then brought me back home oh that's
perfect and it was just you know like it
was
it was like i know my dad just to taste
that glory for i know
like my dad wanted me to have what i
wanted you know like because he wanted
me to feel like i wasn't like at a
different class than the other people
but then my mom was like realistic and
like no we're about to go bankrupt so
he's going to get you know every dollar
counts around here
but that
you know i found i was embarrassed about
that kind of stuff really and were you a
free lunch kid
no well make make my mom made my lunch
every day yeah no i didn't get the free
lunches
i don't think they even had those where
i were you know i was like in a suburb
of seattle it was really it's where
microsoft is and microsoft was
microsoft was just starting then okay
sounds not microsoft now no it was the
beginnings but it was turning you could
see it turning um
but you know they were all all of them
were slightly better at sports than me
you know like actually not slightly
better i was a good athlete comparative
to regular people
but they were the elite like they all
played college something or other they
were all on the all-star teams they all
played varsity when they were freshmen
like they all were the guys and here i
was like the one that was like part of
the group that wasn't quite you know
and so when junior high hit i started to
realize there was other ways to get
attention you know besides being a good
athlete it was just being sociable you
know and and being kind of a daredevil
in the sense of like jumping off bridges
into rivers and like you know i i just
decided at one point like despite my
fear i'm gonna be the first to to do
everything when it comes to risky
behavior
jump like there was a bridge that
everyone jumped off of and all my
friends were like oh and we get up there
and they all stand there and i would
just like i just made a decision you're
jumping in the first 10 seconds when
people aren't even waiting people don't
even know you're gonna jump you're gonna
jump because the what the reputation
that that's gonna give you will suffice
and fill you for the one that you're
lacking with the athletes how high up
the bridge
this bridge was it's funny because you
could jump off the bottom of it or you
could climb up to a really dangerous
like that's something to say it's like
my summers we had the metal rafters that
were under the top was a hundred feet
yeah uh from the street
and then there was a good chunk maybe 50
feet 60 feet from these metal rafters
that went down well this one wasn't even
that big because we were pretty young
still i would say it was like 30 feet
you know and then what i was jumping up
was like 40. but i wasn't doing flips or
anything i would just be the first guy i
could never do a flip like
i look back and it's like why was my dad
not having me in backflip training from
the age of two backflip right you know
what i mean
every kid should be in backflip training
because that is something you'll take
with you your whole you know like until
you're 40. in your heart
yeah you know now these days with knees
and repair you know guys are doing it
into their 50s good point
good point this younger generation of
backgrounds are really really helpful
for that yeah but you know in high
school like the one guy that could do a
backflip was a [ __ ] king yeah he was
it was like every assembly it's like all
right we're about to start the assembly
does backflip guy want to do one real
fast out here on the floor get everyone
psyched up yeah
where's our back flipper his name's
daniel or something
he's out there flipping for his friends
oh man he's wearing a tank top again
here he goes
everyone in first period knows he was
wearing a sweatshirt you were a king if
you could backflip yeah you know
i always wish i was the backflip guy
always
yeah he was popular for sure yeah i so i
but getting into high school i then you
know i was like the first guy i had the
early birthday so i turned 16 before
most of my friends so i got my driver's
license first so i was that guy already
like driving around
going to parties what are you driving i
was driving an 88 jetta gl okay and it
was i loved that car
and now i look back and like that was a
cool car like despite like a lot of my
friends got like a nissan pulsar like
they got these you know sorry yeah the
pulsar nx my friend had a toyota truck i
thought that was cool but the jetta was
a stylish car in the 80s
it had a good form it was cut really
well you know and then i actually
graduated
no this was a brother but it was a
manual it lasted forever yeah man only
friend that had a manual by the way
which was another like
chalk up for me like any one time
anytime somebody got my car they're like
whoa
you're an adult you know what you know
you gotta do you know how to do adult
stuff but i remember dude the best
memory was i had a friend's dad who had
a manual that would drive us to school
sometimes and i remember the feeling of
it i just couldn't i loved it i would
sit in the back seat and feel go all the
way up and come back and hit around
corners and it was like a thunderbird he
had
um more of a sedan type thunderbird but
i
when i got my car we got it like an hour
out of seattle i went with my brothers
and my dad my dad had a honda accord man
or automatic
we get the jetta my dad gets in i don't
know i've never driven a stick i've
never gotten into it oh really you
hadn't even known all right i've been in
them and i knew i knew the feel of it i
knew the timing i i kind of knew all of
it but he drives us 45 minutes and gets
off the freeway and i'm driving my
brothers now in his car and he pulls
into a 7-eleven and the 7-eleven has a
full hill drop into the parking lot
right so we pull in he gets out throws
me the keys and says all right see at
home gets in with my brothers and just
takes off so now i'm sitting there like
no idea
about yeah that's a good lesson
i went in and i was like hey when you
drive a stick shift like the guy at
7-eleven i was like you dropped the
clutch and then you know like i was
trying to figure that out and i get in
and i'm like
so i back it around i get that you know
but in the jetta also it was a push down
and then i got it to where i could get
up the hill but i couldn't start it i
couldn't get it going once i was on the
hill so then i would basically get up to
the top of the hill and watch and wait
for the biggest window possible reverse
down and just i gunned it out no
stopping no stopping at the top of the
hill
stopping at the top of the hill nothing
and i remember pulling up my dad was
like in the in the like the dining room
window just like
yep
he made it like that's back when like
you know like in like the medieval days
they like let their son kill a wolf or
something you know that that's basically
the
i think equivalent to that
so
i you know and then i just started
partying and it wasn't crazy but it was
out of control
and it started to ruin my life
immediately in the sense of like
behavioral issues i never respected
authority i never had good grades and it
just got worse you know and i got caught
drinking it let me ask you were you was
it that you your grades are one thing
but were you just was it not
um en entertaining enough for you school
was it not no challenging enough for you
that was like this is so easy my mind is
out the window and looking at like what
would it be like to be like the lead
singer of you two you know like i'm
thinking about you like i'm
and they're like all right so time to
turn in your your quiz it's like oh
there it is you know like d's i was
getting d's
and i was maybe getting a c and if i had
a b which happened a couple times it was
like the biggest celebration my parents
you know but also it's like hey it's
just a beat we're not going to give you
too much here but we listen we highlight
the flippers
come on out here
get in the kitchen daddy no
nick you got to be good he's got a tank
top on come on in bud he means business
do you ever feel overwhelmed by the
number of plastic bottles and containers
that you throw away ever thought about
purchasing more eco-friendly products
but didn't know where to start well if
you answered yes to either of those
questions meet blue land blue land is on
a mission to eliminate single-use
plastics by reinventing home essentials
that are good for you and the planet
blue lands innovative tablet refill
solution takes up 10 times less space
than a traditional bottle and their
powerful formulas keep your home clean
and smelling amazing the idea is simple
you grab one of the beautiful forever
bottles you fill it with warm water you
drop in the tablet boom you get cleaning
refills start at two dollars and you
don't have to buy a new plastic bottle
every time you run out you can even set
up a subscription so you never run out
of the products you use the most from
cleaning sprays to hand soap to toilet
cleaner and laundry tablets all blue
lamb products are made with ingredients
you can feel good about try their clean
essentials kit which has everything you
need to get started products come in
refreshing signature scents like iris
agave fresh lemon and eucalyptus mint
for a limited time their hand soap is
getting a summer upgrade with three
refreshing new scents strawberry rhubarb
citrus patchouli and coconut palm right
now you can get 15 off your first order
when you go to blueland.com honeydew
that's 15 off your first order of any
blue land products at blueland.com
honeydew blueland.com
honeydew you just need to take better
care of yourself is not a response to
mental health struggles you know you
live with it so sometimes you need
something more to achieve a real and
lasting breakthrough and maybe it's time
you check out a guided ketamine therapy
program from mindbloom minebloom is the
leader in at home ketamine therapy
offering a combination of science-backed
medicine with clinician and guide
support for people looking to improve
their mental health and well-being
mindbloom connects patients to licensed
psychiatric clinicians to help them
achieve better outcomes with lower costs
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience to begin take
mindbloom's online assessment to
determine if mindbloom is right for you
if approved you'll schedule a video
consult with a licensed clinician where
you'll discuss your goals and
expectations for mental health treatment
mindbloom will send you a kit in the
mail complete with medicine treatment
materials and tips for getting the most
out of your experience after only two
sessions eighty-seven percent of
mindbloom clients reported improvements
in depression and 85 percent reported
improvements in anxiety it's time to
enter the next chapter in mental health
and well-being let mind bloom guide you
right now mind bloom is offering my
listeners 100 off your first six session
program when you sign up at
mindbloom.com honeydew and you use the
promo code honeydew at checkout go to
mindbloom.com honeydew promo code
honeydew you're going to get 100 off
your first six session programs today
that's mindbloom.com honeydew promo code
honeydew my good buddy gary adler's got
a brand new comic book out gary's
literally had his
fingerprints all over the studio and
everything it's called commando place
number two
all right the first one was kick ass
it's called speed runners paradise if
you are a comic book fan i'm telling you
this is the way to go it's a great read
um he's got the third one coming out
this fall so i wanted to give a little
love and a shout out to gary adler and
commando place go find it now let's get
back to the dude
and uh so what is your what are you
doing are you drinking are you smoking
drinking
hot and i remember i had a fake idea i
was the only guy that got it [ __ ] how
old at this point i was 16. damn so i
driven downtown seattle into the u
district and got this oregon state id it
wasn't a driver's license you know just
a laminated red card that my name was
glenn michaels is what i came up with
because i love this skier named glenn
plake
that's how we're going to id for this
episode
aka
michaels
actually yesterday would have been my
fake id birthday
[Laughter]
i'm glenn michaels and we go to a party
right and
now it's like around like i'd gotten
booze that night i went to this i went
to one place that was like the place
that i knew didn't give a [ __ ] so they
give me booze i take it to the party
party's going booze is running out there
is there was a keg there that's running
out
and uh some of the guys are like nick
has a fake id and so then this guy named
chris gregory who was the stud i mean
he was the guy he was a year ahead of us
but he looked like an nfl player and he
was on our football team i mean he was
like
looking like
camp chancellor the way that this guy
would take people out he was just a head
hunter you know and it was he was a stud
and he had a jeep a wrangler and he goes
i'll take you down to get it and i was
like nervous you know so chris gregory's
gonna take me down i'm not gonna turn
that down so i hop in the jeep we get
down we get in he goes i go in the store
i got a whole [ __ ] laundry list of
[ __ ] to get you know
yeah paper and i go in and i'm like
getting all the stuff and i go up to the
counter and i'm like uh and i put it
down
and uh she goes uh
hey i remember you from earlier but let
me get another look at that id
and i was like okay and i show it to her
and she goes yeah this this isn't gonna
work and she kept it
no and i go okay well i'll go put all
this back and i just grabbed it and ran
out the door like there's no
no chance i'm getting into chris
gregory's car without this boost or
you're right we're getting back to the
park right you got one of these yeah
i remember us like a 12 pack i got a 12
pack of bud light for some reason i had
like a miller natural ice like whatever
like it was like four boxes the bud
lights just spill out throughout like
because it's a gas station also just
spill out and they're like [ __ ]
foaming
jump in the car go go go go
now you gotta start [ __ ] driving now
he's a getaway driver he pulls around
the corner and as we're driving down
like one of the four like the force main
streets in redmond washington right it
was like redmond way we're driving down
coming the other direction cop car
just goes right by us yeah it was a
small you know like it just happened
that fast around there and um we just
kept driving up to the party legend
status immediately
and once you get like up to that place
and now rumors are being told about you
my brothers were hearing about me
they're five years younger they're
hearing about me at school now they're
hearing about their older brother and
like the stuff that he's done
and um
are you drinking nightly are you
drinking at home i was i was beginning
to drink
nightly like sneaking out drinking my
parents stuff having hidden stuff too
yeah smoking pot uh all my friends would
like get caught and then blame me i was
like the fall guy for everything always
took it always took it always got
grounded always like persevered
got through got back out didn't let it
hold me back
i
i mean but i was a i was a maniac and
like my brothers were um
in basketball
at their junior high which was just
around the corner redmond junior high
was at rim in high school
and one of the guys
in in my um
brother's like basketball team called my
brother a [ __ ]
and my brother was just crushed he was
crying you know he thought like everyone
thought he was you know like in that
time that was like so
you know this is 96
so that's like a pretty harsh thing to
call somebody and then like a rumor to
go around
so the next day i drove my jet up and i
pulled into the bus lane right outside
the gym ramen junior high left the car
running high school kid yeah walked into
the gym basketball practice is happening
all the bleachers are up against the
wall you know like yeah they're like
retracted up against the wall and i i
and i walk up and jacob sees me my
brother and he's just like oh god what
and i go where is he which one
which one and he points at the guy and i
walked up and he was close and i grabbed
him and lifted him up against the
bleachers and i said if you call my
brother a [ __ ] one more time i'm gonna
suck your [ __ ] dick
and i walked out
got in my car and drove off
that guy
first of all did not mess with my
brother again
second of all
second of all my brother gets becomes a
police officer and gets me and he's not
anymore but he was for a while and he he
quit but he he hired he got them to hire
me to come play their holiday party do
stand up at it and right before i'm
about to he goes hey by the way that guy
that you uh he's actually one of my
co-workers now and we're cool we laugh
about it you know but just so you know
he's here now too
and real quick before you go out daddy
get your hands in here bro let's do
those back flips warm them up for nick
all right
she should have a tank top but we'll see
danny's back
god right next to the guy at the
bleachers just like what just talking
about the police event
i mean anywhere danny could pop out and
it's going to be a great scenario oh
yeah that's [ __ ] great and at that
point i wasn't too far away from rehab
and getting kicked out of school i got
suspended
i got in a fight in a church parking lot
around the corner from our school saint
judes that's where all the kind of bad
[ __ ] went down after school
some guy
whatever the stories
it was just dumb we just were circling
each other in this parking lot you know
and everyone's there people from other
schools had heard about it that
happening that day they're there
he's a year older than me but he's
shorter than me but he's pretty like
kind of
i don't know how to explain him but he's
like a little gangster you know
and uh he
we're circling and finally he goes i
thank god i'm not your dad cause
everybody knew i was like [ __ ] up
everybody knew that i was going through
some [ __ ] and like i was a bad boy like
not like the bad boy like tough boy but
like bad boy like oh yeah he doesn't
care about any his life or anybody like
he just is like going out and is that
how you felt though
i was so insecure just wanted everyone
to like me
okay and i didn't see it's when you're
that close to it it's hard to see what's
actually happening and what your
perception is you know my brothers told
me years later about like
yeah you were a legend like at our
school during that time you were like
people wouldn't look at us like the
wrong way you know like it was they were
gonna get their dick sucked
they were gonna get their dicks
and so
so you know basically i this guy so he
says i'm glad i'm not your dad like
we're thinking i'm not your mom or
something like because everyone knows
that i'm kicked out of my house i was
actually living
in somebody else's house right now oh
wow wait hold on before all right go
ahead then i want to go back to why you
get kids i just got kicked out because
of my what i was up to like i just it
was like the last straw you know you're
out of the house and i went and lived
with this dude this dude from my school
whose dad owned a taekwondo studio and
that was part of the rules i had to be
in school and be taking taekwondo i
couldn't be suspended again i couldn't i
could live with them
so i'd taken about a month of taekwondo
and really all that first month was
about
like
just
learning the right way to do this and to
do like things like that against a
against like a you know
punching for a minute like getting your
endurance up getting all your like all
these things
and i didn't realize i knew how to punch
like i didn't real it's like one of
those things like when danny larusso was
like i can do in the fence he didn't
realize that he was gonna be blocking
[ __ ]
like oh my god
you know i was gonna apply to real life
and but still i wasn't like a fighter in
my head you know
and so he says that and i go at him and
i miss i miss and finally he hockey
punches me man he hockey needs me he he
somehow gets my shirt over my head and
knees me in the face like i don't know
if he meant to do it i don't know if it
was by accident i mean
i don't know it was a baller move on his
end and it what i didn't realize in the
moment was that my braces my lip my lips
got stuck in my braces and had chipped a
tooth
and um i was gonna i was starting to
bleed out of my mouth i didn't know that
now i'm just shirtless flailing in a
parking lot and i just was
literally like he's going like this and
i just threw one punch
and i'm not a fighter i'm not like i'm
not a badass i'm not anything i just
threw one punch and it hit the spot
knocked him out
like to the floor
caused for a whole month the white of
his eye at school was red no way you
know one of those black guys yeah and
and i got him in the temple there was
just a stream of blood
and he's on the ground everyone's like
finish him you know
i'm realizing right then my lip and i
was like hold on time out time out you
know this guy's on the ground yeah it's
over i'm saying time out though
and then all of a sudden
cops are coming in everyone takes off
the next day at school i walk in and the
security guard at school sees me walking
in he goes what's up timeout
i got back to him
yeah he was involved with the police
because we were students like everybody
at school i mean it was like time out so
it's like even though i did what i did
i still called time out and that somehow
it was like the story of my life like i
wasn't on top yeah whatever
um and then you know three days later my
parents
i get arrested again
um
trespassing what was the first time d d
like not duis but what is it called like
dwis yeah
eyes you had an s on the end of that you
got more than one
no no no no no not dwight
minor in consumption mic oh my minor
consumption minor possession your age
yeah minor consumption of alcohol minor
possession of marijuana
um
trespassing i'd like drunkenly like
drove these are each different times of
being arrested yeah you drunkly drove on
what were you about to say i dropped my
butt we were camping and i saw my buddy
put his forerunner keys in his uh
shoes this is by that bridge we would
jump off mcdonald river or mcdonald
bridge or something over in like duvall
and uh
i pulled his keys out and hopped in his
car and started taking it for a ride
around this field like just
alone just
like
you know just tearing up somebody's yard
and um
that i got a dui and i got um you know
whatever and that caused me to be kicked
out of my friend's house
my dad had to come pick me up at the
police station
and
well the interesting part of it is that
it was may 17th which is his birthday
and i've been not living at the house
for a while you know like so he picks me
up i wake up there's two advil next to
my bed there's a water my dad you know
he's like so like
he loves me so much and doesn't know
what to do but my mom is the really the
stickler of like this is not allowed in
our house he cannot be here he's tearing
our family apart because that's what
happens when there's one person in a
family that is living like that
all of the attention goes to that person
and no one else is being
paid attention to enough and no one's
like they're all just so worried about
this this guy
and i remember my sister went to school
with me she was a you're younger and she
walked up to me in the hallways i would
never even talk to her i mean i walked
by her like she was my neighbors that i
hated or something like she like and she
would hand me a she handed me a note
she's like andrew and jacob wanted you
my twin brothers that are younger
i got it i looked at the notes like
please come home please we love you like
we miss you like heart-wrenching [ __ ] i
remember going in the bathroom and
crying and
and um
so you were closer with them than you
are with your sister i wasn't really
close to any of them i was in my own
world i missed you
and i was abusive at home i was like you
know mentally
like
you know i never
heard anybody at home but i was a
[ __ ]
i was yelling
screaming breaking stuff in the house
punching holes in walls you know they
were scared of me and my brothers
weren't getting loved by me they were
getting like like hey we want a piece of
gum like and i had like bubble gum
like bubble gum flavor cotton candy
flavored i remember this cotton candy
flavored bubble gum and i was like all
right
stick your head in the toilet then you
can have it no you and i literally
watched my brother dip his head in the
toilet and i'm like all right here's a
piece
just a dick
yeah i mean now we love each other so
much and we're so close and
that all of this kind of brought that
out but yeah so i woke up and my dad
said hey your mom won't let you live in
the house anymore still
um and you can't go back to your
friend's house
so i'm going down to oregon which was
common for him for a week to do like a
com work conference in eugene and he
said i'll drop you off at your grandma's
house you can stay with her and then
i'll pick you back up and we'll figure
out what to do after that
so we get down to my grandma's house we
spend the night
he says um
before before i go down to eugene let's
go fishing in the morning also common go
fishing all the time so great wake up at
like four in the morning to go fly
fishing with my dad i think on the
deschutes river or something is what i'm
told which sounds amazing thing that
we've done a lot and so
get in the car with a pillow remember
like sleeping in the car on the way
there and just waking up in a parking
lot to some building in gresham oregon
and because in oregon they have lockdown
facilities in washington they didn't
okay so in oregon you were in and there
was no no escaping it was like jail you
know and the only people that could let
you out was a doctor or your parents on
there like whether we're giving up on
him we don't care get him out we're not
paying anymore or he's healed we're
letting him come home sort of everything
and i look out there's people like white
suits on and white gloves and
rubber gloves you know my dad's just
kind of he's crying in the in the
driver's seat yeah and he just says i'm
sorry and he gets out of the car and i'm
just sitting there and the door opens
they're like are you gonna make this
easy or you know and i just got out and
they took me in i was naked within like
i think three minutes bending over
and they were um licking my [ __ ]
and that was
no they were you know like looking for a
knife like i've had a knife jammed up my
ass that i was trying to you know get in
there or something and
and uh drugs and whatever this is what
like 5 a.m now yeah
from portland aggression whatever that
drive is
and uh
immediately got put into this room
and
and then immediately had to go into like
a class
you know like i'm just like this is a
whirlwind thing right you know tell me
to walk me through this like you go into
this class how many people are in there
like are they 15 or 20 male female a mix
uh age ranges or whatever
you're under all
yeah most of them are around my age and
uh most of them were in there for g's in
there like nine years old and [ __ ] no no
no
that's a different facility for that
that's a different facility that's just
daycare i think
i remember walking into the the um first
little thing and everyone's at desks
like those school desks you know that
are like that have like the thing and
the chairs attached and then
um
i'm sitting there and one of the girls
says like that i'm cute
turns out she's got a treatment
relationship going on with some other
guy in there and so the second they
break to go into small groups that guy
gets up and starts charging at me from
across the room and i see it coming and
i'm just like uh and i just grab the
desk and share and throw it
you know it doesn't hit him it doesn't
do anything
it just causes a huge disturbance and
makes me look like i'm a psycho
so i get immediately put into the padded
qr room quiet room that they called it
where you're just
strapped down you're strapped at the
beginning of it they came in unstrapped
me and you know like after they thought
i'd calm down even though i was like not
ever not calm i was like nobody saw what
happened you know and they've got a
camera in there and the lady at the
front desk is watching you and you know
they let you out after a certain amount
of time and how long have you spent in
there i don't know it wasn't it was
probably like a half hour it wasn't it
wasn't like crazy but it it was this was
two hours into
waking up in a parking lot i mean
[ __ ] been spread open people are
charging you you're in a padded quiet i
mean
one thing that happened 120 minutes dude
one thing that happened that was amazing
is i was wearing my fishing pants which
my fishing pants
had
regular pockets here but then also
inside that pocket there was a zipper
with a deeper pocket inside so you had
two front pockets on either side and in
one of my front pockets the inside one i
had a tin of uh copenhagen
and i loved i was a chewer and smoker
and everything you know
and they didn't see that and they didn't
check that inside pocket and those are
the pants the only pair of pants they
gave me and my only t-shirt was another
thing
and um
i then had chew and i was using i was
bartering chew like a guy gave me his
contact case
i filled up his contact case with chew
brought it to the next thing and he gave
me adderall i'd never even done adderall
i've never done any drugs besides weed
and but now i'm in rehab where i'm
learning about they're teaching me like
hey drugs new drugs drugs are actually
pretty cool you know like you hear the
way you're hearing about them you're
like oh wow i want to try that drug you
know
and i remember i had like a a fire like
thing in my room and i'd taken uh
a piece of paper wrapped the um adderall
in and put it in there and then i put
deodorant on my hand to reach in and
stick it and pull it out and i was like
trying these adderall and
and and i started realizing like to get
out you gotta you gotta change you know
there's another way to get out of this
place or i gotta turn 18. and um so i
started faking it like immediately and
then i bought into it then i realized oh
yeah i've got a problem the way that i
was acting is not normal it's being in
here what when was that moment what hit
you i think that happened like two weeks
in
and okay so let me stop you there for
one moment the two weeks that you're
spending in there at first
are you pissed at your parents like what
are your emotions about being in the
scared angry fear what are you so angry
what are people in school you're gonna
think i can't talk to anybody no i don't
have any like my parents came down for
like a weekend so in person like the
only therapy session
yeah um i wouldn't talk to them they'd
be like hey your your mom called your
grandma called me like yeah tell him to
take a [ __ ] hike
um and i felt like protected in a way
you know like hey i'm in here also what
a story this is now like people are
gonna be like wow nick did this you know
like in my old mind thinking i'm
thinking like oh this is gonna
perpetuate this kind of thing which it's
not even a thing anymore it's actually
what i am i'm actually this kind of bad
kid
it's not like a cool allure anymore
because we're all about to graduate and
i'm just gonna be a piece of [ __ ]
and it's not gonna be cool anymore you
know
but the thing that hit me that i've told
so many people that have children that
drink that have you know people that in
their lives that have a problem or if
they have a problem
i realized that being in there
wasn't normal
it wasn't an accident
it wasn't a string of accidents that led
to me getting stuck in a rehab my friend
tom would never have been in there my
friend ramen never would have been in
there all my friends
would never accidentally make it this
far into rehab
it is if it looks like a problem and it
smells like a problem it's a problem
it's not and just that that this is not
normal
like i say to people going to an aaa
meeting
that's not normal
okay
going just assume just like let me try
it out that's not normal people that
don't have a problem don't think let me
try out an aaa meeting
they don't people that don't have a
problem don't go to bed like i'm not
going to do that again they don't
they just don't there's people that are
normal and then there's people that
aren't
and
i was not normal none of that was normal
and i got a whole [ __ ] show full of
these people yeah
i know it's like you know and then i
when i got out i changed i don't
understand that like
i've had a lot of addicts sit across me
and tell me things like they're blown
away when i tell them i could finish
half a beer just to have a beer and
leave they're like i can't i can't yeah
not only that like if i haven't even
i'll have 20 and they're like i'm not
exaggerating it just won't even i can't
stop and i'm like i understand what
you're saying so was it was it like that
for you too were you yeah i mean but you
just said like drinking a beer i
wouldn't be holding a beer
at that age yes beer this is so you know
what happened though was i then went to
12 years of pretty much being sober okay
so you got out at what point uh i got it
i got in no i got out at like six weeks
six weeks okay
because two weeks in you're like [ __ ]
this is not normal and i am gonna commit
to yeah and then i loved it i was like
learning you know but there's like we
were even getting getting let outside
we were in a lockdown facility you know
then they transferred me to another
facility that had outdoors and stuff and
then i got sent home did you have any um
what did that girl call relationship no
yeah no yeah
i was heartbroken too
the reason i got into that fight with
that guy was over a girl that had dumped
me and broke in my heart and apparently
he was seen like
with her at a party in a way that i
didn't like the sound of
and uh
so
you know i i remember i had her
also in one of my pockets that they
didn't take out was her picture i had a
picture of her school picture
that's all you had of people you know
and i remember having it on my dresser
and then one day it fell behind my
dresser
you can't move dressers in rehab yeah
they're they're bolted down
pictures because it's possible suicide
yeah it was gone and i remember like
saying like hey i need somebody to come
get this picture out i needed somebody
to and they were like you know like no
and then finally i was just like i
needed that picture to go back there i
needed to stop looking at that you know
and like causing this like a lure of
heartbreak it's not that's not what's
happening that was a [ __ ]
relationship
you're a kid this is what's happening
you know and
i remember getting out and i had this
moment where i like walked out because
my parents had been sending me to church
a lot you know my whole life
because i was bad and they were like you
know they started going to church just
to make it so i would go is that right
yeah wow yeah and
i was going into the youth group and i
loved youth group because that was also
my reputation
you know like preceded me like they all
knew about me and i was cool i was like
the bad kid you know and
then i got sober and i remember walking
out
and none of my friends knew where i was
that whole time nobody knew my parents
didn't tell anybody where i had been i
was just disappeared
and i walk out and this guy curt pulls
up who was the sound guy at the high
school church group he had a he had a
jedha gli
those are nice those are nice nice yeah
red it was beautiful had turbo and it
had everything he pulls up yeah he had
three star rooms
he eventually gave me that car when i
moved to l.a i drove down i drove down
to l.a in that car yeah well i drove
down in a u-haul towing that car
it was lowered you know everything
um
and this guy pulls up and i see my
buddies like walking down the street and
i had a decision it was like that robert
frost [ __ ] right there hold on from
literally walking out of this [ __ ]
facility here they get driven home okay
i remember we we're close to home and my
dad who picked you up
my parents did parents okay so mom came
for this dad dropped you off but mom's
there for the pickup
no
i was in somebody else's car but the car
overheated when we were about in tacoma
like an hour from home and we i remember
having to walk off the freeway with this
guy and with gallons of water come back
and like do it and then we like got home
and i remember getting home and it was
that quick like i walked out my parents
had called kurt to tell him i was home
because they wanted me to be with
him and the neighborhood all the kids
are hanging out my neighborhood all the
time like everyone's out skateboarding
and stuff
and uh i see them and see kurt and i was
just like hey guys yeah crazy i'll call
you when i get back and i just got in
the car with kurt and kurt would do this
thing where just drive you around the
lake like and just talk you know like
listen he'd be like have you heard this
song and play a song and
we want to get a slice of pizza you know
like it was just like a guy that was
trying to keep me out of trouble
and
and
and what a great job he did i mean
that's nice you got someone occupying
your time yeah and then i went to a
church
yeah okay a church camp pretty soon
after that um where i like found jesus
you know and like
saw it and felt it and and like
wanted to believe it
and also saw this kind of thing where
it's like oh
i'm repairing in a lot of ways and part
of the program of aaa is finding a
higher power
and like so this is helping me out there
also
being around these people isn't bad you
know the thing about churches is is
minus the people that suck
it's a brilliant idea
right yeah what like like let's just
break down
the actual basis of a church is it's a
place where anyone in the community is
welcome
right that's the reality of it supposed
to be yeah yes well that's it without of
christianity is all are welcome yes
without the people that have changed
that the people that right god wouldn't
even like
the people that don't represent him at
all without those people what a
brilliant place to go and feel welcome
and helped the way that kurt helped me
like that's that's what's good about it
you know and i saw all that and i loved
it and i wanted to get involved and i
liked helping people now and i like
speaking i remember i went back to that
rehab center like a year sober and spoke
to the kids that were there that's nice
and i was like speaking at high schools
and you know i ended up graduating
and got really involved in church and
just like was a leader like i ended up
in the worship band you know and
i also like nobody looked at me like
this guy's spiritually like can answer
my questions but i was kind of the show
like the showcase like oh you want to
see somebody whose life's turned around
right nick get up here tell them your
story hold on real quick daddy get your
tank top on son flip out here fire it up
from nick get wait wait about 10 minutes
let him get to the part where he was wet
in the bed and then i want you to throw
a flip out
[Laughter]
frank for cupcakes
we're gonna break for cupcakes
yeah this episode of the honeydew is
brought to you by zipix toothpicks
zippex brings you a totally satisfying
convenient and flavorful way to curb
cravings and relax with two milligrams
and three milligram options remember
when massive vape clouds ashtrays and
dip spit were awesome
now there's an easier less messy and
more subtle way to curb cravings with
zipit toothpicks the best part about
zipix is that you really can use them
just about anywhere zipik's toothpicks
are long lasting and available in six
delicious flavor choices plus you can
stop exposing your lungs to smoke and
vape fog it's the oral gratification and
amazing flavors that keep us coming back
to zippex they only sell their
toothpicks online making it one of the
most cost effective alternatives
available also if you need a boost of
energy you can try their zip energy b12
and caffeine toothpicks go to
zipixtoothpicks.com today and use code
honeydew to save 10 off your order
that's zipixtoothpicks.com
promo code honeydew you must be 21 or
older to order zip more smoke less with
zip x toothpicks if you are like me and
there's a foreign language that you
regret not learning in school it's never
too late to start with babel i started
doing spanish in like 8th grade and went
all the way to 11th got a d in it y'all
uh so babel is the language learning app
that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions thanks to babel's fun and
easy bite-sized language lessons you can
finally cross learning that new language
off your list i'm taking spanish like
i've told you and i really do love it
i'm just sitting and driving in the car
listening boom lesson sit at home
sitting around boom lesson it's easy
it's quick and with babel you only need
10 minutes to complete a lesson so you
can start having real-life conversations
in a new language in as little as three
weeks other language learning apps use
ai for their lesson plans but babble
lessons were created by over 150
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective and with babel you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german plus
babel speech recognition technology
helps you to improve your pronunciation
and accent there are so many ways to
learn with babel in addition to lessons
you can access podcasts games video
stories and even live classes plus it
comes with a 20 day money back guarantee
so start your new language learning
journey today with babel right now you
can get up to 55
off your subscription when you go to
babel.com honeydew that's babel.com
honeydew for up to 55 off your
subscription babble language for life
now let's get back to the duke oh
man okay yeah and i loved it and then i
i stuck with it you know i stayed sober
and then i decided to move to la because
i what age are you coming here 24 okay
so from what you said 16 17 you're
getting now that rehab so eight years
you're clean and sober six years six
years six years yeah and you're no yeah
about yeah about eight years and you're
coming to los angeles and i come to los
angeles and it was about a year until i
started smoking weed and taking pills
but i didn't drink for 12 years okay 12
from being from when i got sober okay um
and you know i started stand up what
pills are you taking
whatever the weight is that the laugh
factory would give me
you know
and uh you know but it started going
from like you know like hey you want one
of these like to hey can i stop by your
house and get and get 30 of those
tomorrow at noon you know like
immediately i didn't realize i had an
opiate addiction oh okay and i was still
involved in church a bit when i moved to
l.a and i went to africa on this um to
kenya for like this
it was like a mission trip but we were
like you know it's like
it was like this really cool thing this
area called kaibera which is like the
size of central park but a million
people live in it with no water no power
damn a million people wow it's it's
something i'd never could ever imagine
in my life
dude i remember we were driving in there
and we like go over this like man-made
bridge and standing in the middle of the
bridge is a tv crew and there's a white
guy on camera and as we drive by it's
[ __ ] dean kane
nah
doing right yeah doing some video
being like
what
kibera in kenya what is going on
anyways three days into kenya i thought
that i was sick i thought i had malaria
or something but what i was doing was
coming into opiates yeah it was bad it
was taken to the kenyan hospital and
shaking it fainted in the shower damn um
yeah taken to the hospital how many
pills at your worst uh how many pills a
day were you taking
you know it was like basically on you
would go on milligrams of like how how
strong the pills were and then you're
also cutting in how much of that is a
seed of finance or you know whatever
that's called is that what it's called
yeah acetaminophen is the word
acetaminophen acetacidophene cinnamon
but you're like you know you're doing
math like okay so how much actual
tylenol am i taking and how much drugs
am i taking and you know you're you're
constantly like doing math but i was
popping like
i don't know there's people that do like
40 a day yeah i've heard some numbers
that are just outrageous i'd say i was
like at 15 probably off and on but like
vicodins weren't doing it for me anymore
percocets if i could get them
lower tabs what i forget feel like one
of them was called that anyway
so i went through detox in kenya without
knowing it
and um got home and then
just i don't know didn't get back into
pills i don't know what it was i was
like just got more into marijuana
and then i i i'm the first time i drank
again i mean it's
it's in a movie man it's like just you
want to know you want to see somebody
who's got a problem this is what happens
so now i've made it and stand up enough
to where i've done the tonight show
i had a comedy central half hour
uh i was touring regularly and i was
like on the up and up getting pilots all
this stuff
thinking i can handle booze you know
like what am i doing like i'm
like i should have booze now i mean i
just got married
and i
plan out then i have a gig in vegas and
i plan out you're gonna drink i'm gonna
drink at this gig i'm gonna try it out
how many years
12 years of not drinking okay 12 full
years yeah okay
so i get there
and first thing i do is check in it was
to the palms remember those shows they
used to have at the palms yeah and i go
down to the pool and i order a drink and
i don't order a beer i order a like
what's the equivalent of like a long
island iced tea but it's got like
absinthe and all this stuff you know
it's like some fancy drink because i
remember like
mitch hedberg had a joke about absinthe
and i you know i wanted to try it
because of that joke and i you know all
these things and i um
feel great go up to my room
pass out on the bed you know just like
laying in the bed watching tv and wake
up to just
pounding on the [ __ ] door and i'm
like looking around i'm like so confused
and i open the door it's security
they're like you're supposed to be on
stage 10 minutes ago
whoa
really the opener had gone they've been
trying to call me been trying to get
into my room
that's how quickly
booze affected my career and my life was
just that that was that should have been
the okay but that's the problem is
you've done it now and it's you know
there's no peeling it back it's like if
you're off sugar and then you have a
gummy bear it's like
you're gonna finish that bag
you know
you're gonna finish the bag i mean and
then you know what you're gonna start
eating bags every day yeah that's what's
gonna happen and then you're gonna have
to get off it again and that's gonna
suck
and but that took me 10 years of just
okay
you know of what uh 10 years of a
gradual immediately knowing i'm an
alcoholic immediately being able to look
at myself in the mirror saying you're
lying to yourself and to everybody
but continuing to do it
and
slowly it overtaking every part of my
life you know like missing flights you
know like
small things you know but it's like
business like you don't do that
you know you're not
you know you can think you're an artist
but you know
artists probably do their job and part
of your job is getting on that plane you
know except for the select few that you
know
were wild and you could see that that's
fine
but that wasn't working for me it
doesn't work for most people and so
i
eventually get to you know there's a lot
that happens in here i mean i'm talking
like
walked off a second store
balcony on an airbnb in in minneapolis
landed in the grass
should have died should have broken my
neck what do you mean you walked off it
did we get into this airbnb on this tour
that i'm doing
we have a day off and so i rented this
airbnb it's like on a lake you can't
even swim in this lake it was like you
know a bit like right out of minneapolis
yeah yeah and it was summer and i took
the master bedroom and in the bat master
bedroom there was a door
open it and it just goes out to nothing
there used to be something there yeah
yeah and there's signs like don't open
door right
but my problem was is that i didn't just
like drink and pass out i drank and then
my life started you know like i black
out and then i'm starting doing i'm like
walking around and doing [ __ ] and i was
already to the point to where like you
make mistakes like you've done this
before what like what about what
happened in anchorage like you you can't
let that happen again
i'll tell that too but the anyway i've
yeah i just like in the middle of the
night i just walked out walked out the
[ __ ] you could you definitely died from
that yeah did you break any bones or
anything you're so [ __ ] phased you fell
out relaxed no it didn't hurt
yeah
you know you know what happened there's
this story of townsvanzant that he tells
in this like
this recorded message with his manager
that they have on one of his albums
and and it's in and it's basically like
saying how he fell off a balcony just
because he wanted to know what it felt
like to fall you know he wanted that
feeling
and i think in my drunken state
i took that on and i wanted to do what
towns vanzant did or something stupid he
broke his neck when he did it like he
did yeah
um
so anyway but no in alaska i was there
with rory and
jen kirkman and
we uh we just got [ __ ] faced when i did
i did everyone else is probably fine and
i get back to the room and i wake up and
so this hotel was really nice in
anchorage all tourists you know and most
people that travel to anchorage are
older
um there was we're on like the 16th
floor is a vip floor you can't get to
the floor without a key you can't get
into the door
past the elevator without another key
and they had the exit stairwells but the
exit stairwell was outside
so like you'd walk out of the hallway
and you're outside you walk down walk
into another hallway walk out again and
it was like that the whole way down okay
you're spiraling yes
and the door though so i wake up pissing
off this balcony at like 6 a.m
wake up you mean you come too and you're
yeah i'm standing on this outdoor
balcony this is what you're seeing
yourself on the 16th floor oh my god
i don't have my room key
i only am wearing underwear and i was
wearing the underwear that i was wearing
at the time was these american apparel
briefs because you could go down that
little thing up front you know where you
used to pee out of
but you could put your hand in there and
it would go all the way
under your butt there was all this
storage area under there oh okay and
that's where i traveled with weed okay i
would double s i would put weed in
turkey baster bags seal them up
double-sided tape under your sack put it
under my sack yeah okay so i was wearing
these brief under orange briefs exactly
what i was wearing that day and i go to
open the door doors locked i don't have
anything
[ __ ] so i start walking down
walking down 16 floors and there's the
last door and i just i don't know what
this door is opening into it's on the
main floor
what the door opened into was an
all-you-can-eat buffet
and it's just
old tourists and i just walk out and
it's like
hey
and i go to the front counter and i'm
like hey i'm like locked out of my room
how many people are in there dude
and they go do you have id
do you have id it's like do i look like
i have id no no
no one like me
no one that's looked like this has ever
had an idea
okay
they're either at a strip club or
they're you know oh hell yeah so they
had to
they had to escort me up to my room so i
could walk in and prove you were you
yeah so that meant sitting in an
elevator for 16 floors in my underwear
with a [ __ ] secure staff
which probably for them is like hey
it's not one of the elderly guys yeah
oh you could eat buffet dude i mean it
was brutal
it was brutal and and so what these are
the types of things that are happening
to me on a regular basis and
so when do you finally go the second
time well when i'm drinking over like
i'm basically drinking a handle of vodka
a day i can't really were you wow yeah i
was buying them in fifths but i would
always have two a day and i would like
have one at home have one in my car have
one in this like hidden drawer above the
cabinet in the bathroom
everywhere i'd show up a part like a
sunday afternoon people are out drinking
in the backyard
normal people
that are enjoying a beer on a sunday
and i'm enjoying a beer too is what they
think
except i'm sneaking to my bathroom i'm
sneaking out to my car i'm sneaking to
wherever i've got hidden vodka and
taking huge drain like five shot just
drinks out of it out of like warm
[ __ ] room temperature vodka and then
walking back out with my beard just like
hey i'm just like you guys you know
and it was it was just getting
horrible and then i get to bloomington
indiana
and i remember the movie um
breaking away
is that a bicycle movie no it was a
bicycle movie that was like 79 or 80.
daniel stern's in it dennis quaid's in
it yes dennis quaid that's what just
made a stick yep and it's shot in
bloomington and it's the whole movie's
about the cutters which is like the
group of like locals against the
university kids because there's a big
university there
and there was a swimming hole scene
where they like hiked to the swimming
hole that's in like lime rock and it's
like this green beautiful thing
it doesn't look worldly you know
and i was in bloomington was like i want
to find that and so then one of the guys
at the comedy club is like oh my my
buddy knows where it is he's heard about
it so the next day this guy takes me on
a two-hour hike through the woods on a
private property where we're seeing like
live ammunition do not enter like all
these signs
[ __ ] that
found it
jumped off of it just like in the movie
swam in it it was [ __ ] glorious you
know
leave
go from there to montreal
[Music]
to where the festival you know didn't go
home and i'm in montreal and like
i'm doing like a week and a half of
shows there i think my own hour
and somebody
sees
a tick
it's right on my scalp it's right on my
hairline right in front there's a tick
that's been in there since bloomington
it's been about five or six days now and
they get tweezers they pull it out
it's intact you know like they put it in
like a little pill thing that i had and
they were like take this to the doctor
when you get home and you know you're
gonna be home in three days or two days
like you should be fine right
i get home and i'm not making good
decisions also i'm not going to the
doctor because i smell like booze all
day every day and they're going to check
me out and i'm probably dying and i was
i really was dying and i didn't really
know how bad you know but like waking up
with liver pains waking up with like
really
you would have physical pain drinking
and anything any day that i tried not to
drink it was vomiting and shaking and
then i had to drink through vomit like
you know drinking trying to get booze
into me so my body would even out and i
was convinced that if i didn't drink my
heart would stop and that was what was
gonna happen
so like i'd wake up at two in the
morning with chest pains go find vodka
wake up at four in the morning same
thing wake up at four stay up till six
drinking vodka then go to bed then my
son's gotta wake up for school like it's
like you know i was just like not in the
world i was living in my own world in
this house and it was tearing everything
down
and um
you know but i get this tick i go back
finally like i'm with my riding partner
maybe a week or two after montreal
and i go like i have this like lesion on
my arm and i go to him i was like isn't
this crazy look at this bruise must have
been from wrestling with my son
you know like you could see like grab my
arm or something
and he was like huh and then like 10
minutes later i'm like oh my god did i
tell you about bloomington i got with a
tick you know i'm telling him the story
i'm also drunk right now you know i'm
always drunk i drink all day
and i don't know this he's googling
ticks
lyme disease
and what's the promo poster photo of
what it looks like is a bull's-eye
lesion is that right yeah
and um he's like you need to go to we
stopped writing right then that's all i
ever heard of k as a kid and as i'm
saying to you before outside like i
don't know what lyme disease is what it
does to your body but everything was as
soon as you get in from the woods
everybody check for ticks yeah cause you
can get lyme disease yeah like that
doesn't sound good we don't want that so
let's check for ticks i mean it's one of
those i've seen them on dogs that they
get oh my god it looks like a bubble
like oh it's just sucking on that
[ __ ] dog for like weeks and [ __ ] like
jesus it's so scary and also there's a
good section of people that don't think
it's real you know really and there's
also would you not think so you know
because it's like it's hard to detect
what's actually happening to you you
know like what it's actually do in your
body and some people have chronic lymes
or they have all these things you know
if you find it early enough like like i
did
i got on these antibiotics and i got rid
of it but i didn't get rid of it until i
got sober i was on the antibiotics for i
think like four months to be honest or
something
they're hardcore
and when you're drinking they just
cancel out
antibiotics i was waking up feeling fine
right
go out to my car besides like the
hangover and all the other [ __ ] going on
in my life
sit down and all of a sudden i can't sit
my tailbone hurts so bad like i can't
sit i never felt that in my life go in
have to get in bed wake up tailbone
feels fine now i can't move my arm like
it's just going between joints you know
and like
the the feeling of exhaustion i mean i
was just sleeping so much and drinking
when i wasn't sleeping you know like
hidden in the closet in the guest room
where i was now living at my house with
like lyme's disease like where the ac
was blowing and i'm just like
you know my friend dies of alcohol
really yeah this amazing
singer-songwriter producer that lived in
oregon he um
we talked a week before he died
and we both realized we were drinking
the same amount
he like faced time i remember he
facetime called me which nobody ever
doing that and like like so weird why
would richard do that and
talking and
you know it's like i gotta stop i gotta
get help like me too man you know like
whatever
and then a week later he goes he gets
taken to the hospital a day later taken
to hospice three days later dead that
quick organ failure gondis like whatever
he turned yellow it happened to a kid i
went to high school with his older
brother i saw a post and i reached out
and just said hey man i'm so sorry what
the [ __ ] happened because his his
brother who passed was my grade and um
he said the same thing he said he never
stopped drinking like we were in high
school and you know college and he just
kept drinking and smoking and he said
one day he woke up his eyes were yellow
went right to the doctor and they're
like we're it's too late for you and
within like i don't know a few weeks he
was gone it's
yeah
so was that so that's your wake-up call
hold on no no eventually it was but that
took me down
i went up i went up and did a memorial
show in portland for him with a whole
bunch of other musicians that he'd
worked with i mean the shins
and i hosted the whole thing at this
cool theater i forget which one it was
at in portland
afterwards everyone
is going out to a bar and i remember
like this was my this was my rough trip
in portland where i ended up having to
stay an extra couple days because i was
so sick
but i remember getting to the bar and
they let everyone in and i barely
remember this but i've been told about
it from a lot of people
that i came up to the door and the guy
just said
no
really and i was like what why and he's
like something's not right about you you
can't come in
like everyone's inside i'm like you guys
and they're like no let him in he's fine
he's fine and you guys like i'm sorry i
can't let somebody like that in here
like whatever state i was in you know
we're coming straight from the memorial
service it was like
oh god it was a bad night and i
continued to go and go and go
and then finally i mean i
i go to the doctor and the line stuff is
being figured out and they got my blood
test back and this is a doctor in malibu
like my appointment was like 10 in the
morning
and um i've been drinking on the way
there you know and and i get in there
and i sit down and he's like looking at
my papers and he's like so you didn't
tell me you were a drinker
and i was like well what do you mean he
goes well your enzymes he goes uh you've
got 360 enzymes in your liver
and again i'm i'm not my i don't know my
numbers might be uh i was drunk i don't
remember all of it but what's that mean
i don't know but i said what does that
mean and he says you're supposed to have
six
oh
wait did you say
six
you have 360. yeah holy [ __ ]
yeah it was like he's like you need to
stop drinking he's like i can help you i
can give you medications to stop
drinking and he like writes out this big
list of things that he's going to start
giving me to help me stop drinking
but i leave there and grab a bottle of
vodka
[Music]
drive up the pass in you know malibu
like over by pepperdine university and
i'm driving and they have these like
little as you're going through the
canyons there
like a pull off you can like pull off
for a view site or something and it
always says no parking
i pulled off on one of those and got out
of my truck
with uh vodka in my hand
and
started drinking like a quarter of it
just while i'm driving you know that's
how sick i was i was driving drunk it
was it's a you know i'm ashamed of
the risk that i put other people through
my problem
and i just started kind of walking down
the canyon off the side of the road
there thinking i'm not coming back
really and i
got then i had like a whole bunch of
pills and
xanax and all this stuff and
halfway down something hits me like oh
if you decide not to die
you might get a parking ticket
in my mind like that was like okay yeah
you can't do this then right you're not
ready
so i went up got in my car drove through
the canyon so drunk it was like i mean
that's that's that's so dangerous it is
beyond dangerous i pull over and i can
even if you know there's no traffic on
that road the whole way to do that
yourself those canyon roads are wildly
[ __ ] uh
dangerous and curvy yeah
it's yeah
i call my best friend riding partner
and i call my manager
and i just say
my hands are up man somebody needs to
come pick me up and save my life take me
somewhere
and my buddy kevin like drives out
picks me up
my manager got me into a rehab you know
managers can do stuff like that
like got me to rehab that day like they
weren't taking people anymore
and it was just really cool like malibu
rehab you know and i came in and they
took a breathalyzer
0.38 jesus christ
from
right from the spot to there yeah i
finished that whole bottle of vodka 0.38
how are you even upright i was talking
how they were fat they were blown away
at my casual demeanor and conversation
and you were holding conversations yes i
was sad i was that sick man i was
drinking so much booze but also the
pills too like
look i'm fortunate i'm allergic to
opiates they make me throw up they make
me break out itch hives the whole nine
it sucks because i also can't take them
for pain
but
that alone i mean i i know how i feel on
those [ __ ] things and then to put a
bottle of vodka on top of it and you're
having conversation yeah .08 maybe it
was 0.32 either way 0.08 or
legal limit and i was well above it over
two above it and um
yeah they they checked me in i woke up
and it just you know the next two days
were an absolute blur of delusions
um i was seeing things they were trying
to keep me alive because you know in
rehab really what they're trying to do
is help you detox comfortably
and then help you get better give you
classes teach you about your addiction
teach you about emotional things that
you're doing you know all this stuff
two days in i'm full on having
conversations out at a back table with
nobody around me and the rehab's
monitoring me they're all watching it
everyone there is like
this is a unique case this guy you know
and they're all just kind of like
letting me and i got convinced that they
were after me like they were going to
check me into a mental institute because
they thought i was mentally breaking
down did you realize you were having
conversations out back by yourself or
was that thing you solve on video later
or they never they never tell you yeah
they um i was entertained they found me
naked out in the backyard finally um at
like 4 a.m or 2 a.m and um i was dying
they rushed me to the hospital
los robles hospital or something
and um i don't know i woke up a week
later a week
they they rushed me in the hospital
and i kind of remember
this moment
where i'm in a movie and i'm getting
wheeled down a hallway and i'm seeing
the ceiling
and
some guy and i'm like try to move my
arms and some guy goes nick
we're trying to save your life you're
strapped down because you've been
combative you hear you hear this that's
all i remember hearing and whatever they
couldn't get an iv into me right they
were trying so hard that combative and
also like just dehydrated and all the
things that i was
and i remember the nurse from the rehab
saying i've never seen someone be
stabbed like they were stabbing you to
get that into your arm to get you to
like knock out because you were being so
like
kicking and punching you were buck naked
you know just like in this hospital
jeez and i remember waking up and it's
like it's funny like i called al
madrigal somehow
i don't remember i don't know how where
i got his number i don't know
but i i'd love to actually talk to al
about that now and be like what was that
conversation like i can't remember
anything but i remember it was like i
was canceling a
show or something i don't know
anyway i'm in the hospital they get me
out and i was just done man i wanted to
live i just i just realized like i can't
do this anymore i wasn't one of the
people there that's like i don't want to
be in rehab i was like i want to be
better
my life is done
it was just finished i now have a second
shot
i've torn everything down
i've i'm you know like living in a house
that i can't afford anymore
i'm not able to work you know i'm doing
all of these things and
yeah i mean our job well hell any job
without your health you don't you you're
not working yeah you know yeah so
especially something like this
i mean it was yeah 60 days i stayed in
there
in the middle of it it burnt down
malibu fires it was crazy i woke up i
woke up at eight in the morning
and it was like that's weird usually
somebody like comes by and knocks on the
window and wakes me up and i go out and
i'm in the kitchen they have this fancy
kitchen where they're serving you know
it's a nice rehab
and i'm like making my lemon juice that
i was making every morning and
people are like scrambling and there was
smoke the night before you know and i'm
like hey so what's the deal with the
fire and they go we have to be out of
here in a half hour
like they were evacuating the place and
somebody just forgot to wake me up nah
cause i was in the furthest room away
from everything and so i run and
scramble get all my [ __ ] i was in the
last car out of there with the nurse and
a dog that they just found a dog
and it burnt down an hour later damn and
we ended up at some like airbnb in
oxnard
where we were like
stayed there for a few days and found
another rehab center to take over and
move into
it was wild and what happens when you
get out
i go home and that was how many years
ago now
uh four in october good for you you've
been sober the whole time yeah oh yeah
good yeah
and uh
my life was just torn down you know i
get home divorce
move out
move in with friends
living in a friend's like downstairs
basement
then the pandemic hits
oh
i'm living in a studio you know like i
basically went down to the ground and am
now getting out good for you dude you
know and everything is
you know like it's
it's better it's good it's not like i'm
not like this guy that's like i'm fixed
and i'm done like i know i'm not and i
go looking for help all the time because
that's the only
you know
i i've learned that you know you're seek
your only
what is the um
you're only as something as your secrets
you're only as sick as your secrets i've
never heard that before you're only as
sick as your secrets and
and no matter how heavy the phone is
it's actually just a button
you know like anytime you need to just
talk to somebody it's so simple
and it's so hard at the same time you
know but understanding that it actually
is simple and that you're creating the
difficulty
and that's a lot of people don't make it
through that a lot of people don't get
past that part and i'm lucky that i've
been able to do enough of the work
to where i am
i'm sending i set boundaries in my life
i i'm i'm doing things where i know that
i'm not putting myself in positions to
go to old behaviors right you know like
right
whether it comes being coming attached
to a woman or like in a relationship
like all these things like if i can't be
you know if i can't just be me
and be happy
like if i need somebody to bring that
then then i'm off there's something
that's wrong you know and i'll get there
and then i'll figure it and i'll back up
and do it again and
it's a you know it's this huge process
but
how do you um i want to ask you this how
do you
deal with i mean our business is a lot
of
weed especially pills alcohol how do you
deal every everywhere you work has
alcohol i'm not tempted good right like
i don't right now and i haven't
i i mean it was so bad that i i know
that i'll lose everything and i can't
lose everything again if there's no
might not be no coming back from that
one i agree most likely not most people
don't make it back out i'm lucky i made
it back out of that relapse your blood
work and everything's good now and
everything yeah i mean you know a year
later a lot of those things fix
themselves if you're young and you
didn't go too far
um
but your brain i mean that takes years
the chemical imbalance there is years
and i remember
you know when i got out i was seeing
somebody and and she kind of ended it
because there's this rule like you can't
be with somebody
in your first year of sobriety they say
oh no relationship at all okay yeah they
just you know it's like best there's
nowhere in a book that says that it's
just like hey realistically you
shouldn't be work on yourself yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and so this woman was like very strong
and and solid in that and i
it just again like took me down to a
place and i remember i
i was trying to call her and try to get
a hold of her and finally we talked and
i was driving on hyperion i remember and
i was just crying i was out of sorts and
she goes
nick the way that you're talking right
now
i've heard people talk like this and
commit suicide that day
the way that you're talking
you need to call your doctor and you
need to get on medication
and they'd offered me medication and
rehab i'm like i don't need i'm not i
don't need that stuff but the thing is
is you've been drinking all the levels
of the things that are going into your
brain to make you feel things are off
and depleted they're gone like my body
can't create serotonin my body can't
make these things that i need to be
level to like be a human i've ruined
that you know
and
she said like like right now who are you
gonna call what's the name and i was
like i'll just call the doctor from
rehab i guess and i just did
and the next day i started medication
you know and it saved my life yeah and
good
you know i'm from the it's funny i've
talked about this because i take my
medication as well and i didn't want to
i felt like
i had no problem with therapy where a
lot of guys are like [ __ ] up i have no
problem with the therapy opening up
talking meditation journaling self-help
self-help but medication to me seemed
like uh a crutch or a cheat code like a
lot of the way i feel like i felt about
medication the way a lot of people feel
about therapy you know i'm like what's
the matter with that and then other
people are like yo and it yeah it works
it's it [ __ ] works and and you don't
always find the right one either like
everyone's body is different oh yeah i
can't tell you how many different
[ __ ] blood pressure medications i
took or whatever until i found whatever
is minimal to my it's funny though
there's so many people that it's not
funny it's realistic and it makes sense
to be honest but a lot of people
are like oh i can't take that anymore
because it makes it so i can't orgasm
or it makes it so i can't like i can't
like get hard like whatever these like
things that they want their body to be
able to do
this medication is affecting that in a
way
and they're not willing to make that
sacrifice
and
and because of that they're going to now
be living with this thing that's
horrible right you know and maybe that
means there's another medication that
doesn't do that you can keep going and
trying and doing whatever but like you
know
the side effects if they're not
life-threatening are so
great
because
i don't i also don't believe that
medications forever
it's you know like my body needed it my
brain needed it and then there's a part
of me that's like you know over the
pandemic i was like i want to start
getting off this and they were like we
we want you to too
let's wait for the pandemic to be over
it's pretty dark right now you know like
you shouldn't be trying to do this right
now by the way they're delivering
alcohol to your house now oh yeah yeah
you know like [ __ ]
that's not the time to do it oh my god
yeah i i mean when i found out about
doordash delivering booze before before
there was like another beverage app or
whatever before the pandemic that's what
a lot of my drinks were getting
delivered like that and i was like
secretly in the middle of the night like
rushing out and grabbing a bottle of
anyways
yeah yeah it it um
you know i'm not like an advocate for
but i'm not like speaking for a company
i just know that what my friend told me
that day
changed my life that saved my life
because it's
you know it's
i realize that i'm not above
the darkest worst stuff
which is suicide which is
you know
thinking that i don't matter thinking
that other people are better off if they
don't have to deal with me in their day
you know but that's the thing is that
those are all
my thoughts right and you know what
those people are also having
their own thoughts
and
to think that everyone is that concerned
about me and that i'm affecting other
people's lives that much is a sickness
that came from my alcohol
you know and now i'm like getting over
it and realizing like oh i don't need to
believe the lie that alcohol has been
telling me all this stuff and yeah and
you know what yeah you've done some [ __ ]
that some people probably are never
going to really want to be
close to you again because of
even if you've changed
and that's not their fault it's your
fault
there's nothing you need to fix it and
there's nothing you can do to like
that's going to dwell like why dwell on
what other people are thinking about you
it's just literally none of my business
which is the hardest thing it really is
it's none of our business somebody
blocked me on no somebody unfollowed me
on instagram a friend
i found it so weird he stopped
responding to my text and he unfollowed
me this is like past so bright i'm like
sober at this point
and i was
in canada shooting something and i
remember like i still followed him so
i'd like see his stuff and every time i
saw him post it like made me think
what's wrong with me why didn't this
person you know like what or like nobody
likes me nobody likes me this guy
doesn't like me you know and then one
day i was in this thing and i was like
who [ __ ] cares what this [ __ ] guy
thinks of you
it does not matter and it's not about
you
because i know that i didn't do anything
to deserve that really i hadn't
and so
i just decided to be okay with it and
then i run into this guy six months
later and he was a sober guy and he's
drinking
and i see exactly why it all happened
he's going through his own [ __ ] just
like everybody else it has nothing to do
with me nothing him unfollowing me was a
fallout because i'm somebody he can tell
that is not gonna be okay with him doing
that yeah so he's getting away from you
yeah
and every time he saw something i posted
he remembered oh nick fixed his life and
now mine's not fake i can't fix
whatever maybe also he just hates me who
cares you know who cares it's not my
business and if i make it my business
you know it's like it's so funny like
how you can like feel out if you've done
something done like you talked to
somebody else like oh you talked to
so-and-so lately yeah i feel like he's
not talking to me has he said anything
like you know all these things like
you're trying to do research to find out
you're wasting so much time then you
find out like someone in their family
died and they're going through a [ __ ]
divorce and they're going through you're
like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah oh [ __ ] my bad
yeah and it's these attachments you know
it's like this insecure this anxious
attachment
that you have to people where
if they're off it throws you off
whereas you can't just be like securely
attached
and if they're having their own thing be
like hey have your thing
i'll be here that's right yeah man
i'm not gonna judge it
i'm not gonna make it about me
which is the hardest thing to do all the
time
you know constantly trying to make
things about myself
like the weather
you know
like
if i really follow the thoughts
everything's about me a traffic jam all
of it it's to keep me from what i need
to do
it's oh i could have done this but now i
can't because of this [ __ ] weather so
obviously
all right so everything we've talked
about
i mentioned before um advice you would
give to your 16 year old self now
everything we said rehab was first at
17. what advice
is a pretty pivotal age for you what
advice would you give yourself
that none of it lasts
all of the things that you're in
don't last you mean good and bad
yeah
they don't i mean but specifically
the insecurities the um
the level of hierarchy in whatever your
clique is or your school or whatever
none of that lasts
we all turn 18 we move on
we come back we see other people people
who are mean to us are now nice
a guy that we thought sucked and was
like better than us at everything is now
working in real estate and doing pretty
well for himself but
probably hates it you know who knows you
know like
no one
it just doesn't last and stop thinking
that what you do that day lasts forever
in these people's minds
and really the only person that you
should be trying to
impress
is the 42 year old version of yourself
you know because the things that i did
right when i look back i'm like wow i
can't believe i had that strength
you know so funny i just said this to a
friend of mine the other day i was like
god if i could just go back as like a a
ghost and hover over my 17 year old self
and watch myself for a little bit like
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what i
mean like you said that out loud what if
you could get those things
yeah but but yes taking that 16 year old
kid and going look i know you're no
parents and you're at your lowest but i
promise you
in
35 years i'm like what i gotta get how
much longer i got to do this [ __ ] dude i
remember at 15 a pivotal moment like how
long
i'm gonna be like that for this long
okay and i'm okay great great i'm not
gonna get any taller okay you know
but i remember when i was 15 a teacher
did this exercise one day where he was
like
let's just break down like
how do you want to live when you're 35
you know you want to be in a house you
want to be in an apartment you want to
live in a city do you want to live in a
suburb do you want to drive a sports car
do you want to drive this car do you
want to have kids do you want to have
this and you go through it and you like
put all that together and then there was
an equation that calculated how much
money you needed to make a year
to support the life that you thought you
wanted to have when you're 35
and then they take that number and they
show you the careers that can earn that
and it's a real
awakening moment i i obviously never
forgot about it you know where i was
just like oh wow
and i lowered i immediately lowered what
i wanted my life to be i was like i
don't need a house
right away yeah cause i'm like
i'm never gonna make that much money
like how am i gonna do that i don't need
a car man
that's great advice though it doesn't
last it doesn't it doesn't no dude thank
you for coming on for real uh this was i
i learned a lot more about you i didn't
know i'm glad you're healthy good for
you thank you uh straight
um and and
would you be interested in going into a
backflip program with me i would love to
dude that would be great a backflip
program remember seeing comedians that
would do i think tripoli might have used
to do a backflip back and i would always
think man like at some point you're not
gonna be able to pull that off you know
i wonder i mean i don't know him as ever
doing a backflip myself if it was him it
might have been him and i talking about
this guy had always did a flip and i'm
like there was a couple guys that do it
mm-hmm there's like a guy now that does
it on stage i think still oh as a young
guy probably yeah i mean but it's worth
it you know it's like i don't know would
you do it yeah [ __ ] it not in stand up i
wouldn't i would you know what i'm doing
man
you don't know uh plug and uh promote
everything again oh yeah october 8th
chicago
the den theater
um
and just you know i don't know
find me on instagram all right
um as always ryan sickler.com ryan
sickler on all social media we will talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you